Have you ever felt like, you
know, suffering is just baked
into being human?
Something you just have to put
up with like a constant shadow?
Like it's just.
The price of admission.
Exactly.
But what if I told you that,
huh?
For a lot of us living today, a
huge chunk of that suffering is
actually optional.
Optional suffering?
Yeah, it sounds almost
contradictory, doesn't.
It it really does.
It's a pretty bold idea.
Challenges everything we usually
assume about pain, about
happiness.
So today we're doing a deep dive
into something really unique.
It's not a massive book or, you
know, some dense academic thing.
It's actually an e-mail.
Just an e-mail.
Yeah, an e-mail shared by our
writer Chris Abraham that he got
from his guru.
And it's short, but wow, it
packs a punch.
It takes this ancient wisdom,
like really old ideas and boils
it down into this shockingly
simple but honestly life
altering insight about why we
suffer and maybe more
importantly, how real peace.
You know what some people call
Nirvana might be way closer than
you've ever thought possible.
So our mission today is
basically to unpack this thing,
this short but powerful message,
piece by piece.
See how it really pushes back
against our usual ideas about
pain and well-being content?
And that's what makes this so
interesting for you listening
right now, because this isn't
about needing APHD in philosophy
or, you know, becoming a monk
for 10 years.
The guru's e-mail manages to
distill like thousands of years
of really deep thinking into
something you could actually use
today in your life.
It's direct, it's actionable.
So we're going to explore how
this message changes the way we
think about living in what the
e-mail itself calls paradise.
Paradise.
Yeah, strong word.
It is, and it's not just about
understanding the words on the
page or screen.
I guess it's almost like a
shortcut to getting properly
informed about your own mind,
your inner world.
OK, I like that.
Well informed about your inner
landscape.
Exactly understanding how your
works in a way that could
genuinely change how you see
suffering and maybe open up a
path to feeling you know more at
peace.
OK, let's dive in then.
So the e-mail starts with this
premise and honestly, when I
first read it, it was like a
light bulb moment.
You know one of those aha things
where you think, why didn't I
see that before?
Obvious in hindsight.
Totally.
The guru just states it flat
out.
Here's why people suffer, and
here's why most of that
suffering is unnecessary.
Boom, just like that unnecessary
suffering.
Yeah, think about that phrase,
unnecessary suffering.
It's powerful because it
directly confronts how we
normally think, right?
Where suffering is just a given,
something we have to bear.
Absolutely.
It reframes the whole struggle.
And I think what often gets
missed is just how powerful
simplicity can be.
We're sort of conditioned,
aren't we, to think profound
truths have to be wrapped up in
complicated language or hidden
away in, like, ancient rituals.
Yeah.
You need the secret decoder
ring.
Right.
But here the guru shows that
sometimes the biggest insights
are the ones laid bare, direct,
unambiguous.
And that clarity, not trying to
obscure things, that's where the
power lies.
It immediately takes suffering
from being this fixed fate we
just accept.
Yeah, passively endure to.
Being something we actually have
some control over, some agency,
it flips the script from
resignation to active choice
which.
Immediately makes you ask,
right?
Exactly makes you listening.
Ask OK if most of my suffering
is unnecessary, what does that
actually mean for me day-to-day?
What parts that the heaviness I
feel might actually be optional?
It forces you to kind of take
inventory.
And what's amazing is how this
like really modern sounding idea
connects straight back to
ancient wisdom.
The.
Roots are deep.
The guru explicitly mentions
Buddhism, reminds Chris, the
recipient, that this whole
tradition started with
Siddhartha Kotama.
Who became the Buddha?
The awakened 1.
Exactly.
And like 2500 years ago, the
Buddha shared this core insight.
Life is full of suffering, Duka,
that's undeniable.
Right, the first noble truth.
But, and this is the crucial
bit, that suffering can end the.
3rd noble truth.
Liberation is possible.
Yes, and how?
By understanding where it comes
from, its origins.
And then this is key learning
how to let go.
That art of letting go sounds
simple, but it's profound.
And it's not just some dusty old
concept.
The gurus e-mail pulls it right
into the present.
Makes it intensely practical for
us now.
That connection is so important.
It really sets the stage for
applying this ancient stuff in a
totally contemporary way.
Like you said, the Duru isn't
saying, right?
Drop everything, shave your
head, find a cave.
Yeah.
No, definitely not.
Quite the opposite.
Yeah, the genius here is taking
these timeless principles about
existence and suffering and
applying them to your modern
life, which, let's face it, is
wildly different from ancient
India, but still full of its own
discomforts.
Oh, for sure.
Different stresses, same basic
operating system maybe?
Exactly.
And the e-mail gives this
incredibly practical, almost
immediate path to letting go.
It bridges thousands of years.
Take something that can feel
really esoteric and just grounds
it right here, right now.
Makes it relevant to your job,
your relationships, your
anxieties.
It reminds us that suffering
itself, that basic human
experience, hasn't fundamentally
changed, even if the, you know,
the wallpaper is different.
We'll put the context changes,
the core mechanism often
doesn't.
So to make this even clearer,
more memorable, the guru
categorizes suffering and he
uses this very direct term.
He calls it the shit.
OK, doesn't mince words, does
he?
Not at all.
Which honestly, I find kind of
refreshing.
It cuts through any spiritual
pretense, yeah.
Get your attention.
So the first seven things on
this list are the raw
fundamental experiences, stuff
humans have always dealt with.
Thirst, hunger, exposure to the
elements, sickness, horniness,
injury, tiredness.
Primal stuff, biological
imperatives and vulnerability.
You can almost feel those, can't
you?
They're visceral.
Totally forces that absolutely
shaped human history.
But then and then comes #8 after
all those physical, biological
things, he adds one more
distinct, crucial OK.
What is it and?
Then there's one more your
brain.
There it is, the pivot.
And that clear split is just so
critical, isn't it, for
understanding where most modern
suffering actually comes from.
Exactly.
Those first seven, yeah, they're
mostly physical, primal,
biological needs or challenges.
Always been part of the deal,
tangible things, body
interacting with the world.
But #8 your brain that's purely
psychological, internal and
calling the whole is the shit.
It's blunt, sure, but it's
brilliant.
You won't forget it.
Definitely not.
And it immediately helps you
listening, start to sort your
own feelings of suffering.
Is this thirst or is this, you
know, anxiety about work?
Is it physical or is it
generated up here?
Right, that distinction is the
first step to actually doing
something about it.
Precisely, it gives you a
framework.
Now, to really get why this
message is so, well,
revolutionary, we need to do a
quick mental time travel.
Think about human history for
almost all of it.
That shit list wasn't just a
concept, it was the brutal day
in day out reality.
The.
Absolute baseline of existence.
Imagine really being thirsty.
Not just oh I could use a drink,
but debilitating thirst with no
clean water source guaranteed.
For real hunger, not I missed
lunch, but days, Weeks of
gnawing emptiness, the real fear
of starving.
Exactly.
Freezing in winter, baking in
summer, no proper shelter,
getting sick from something
minor like a cut and knowing it
could kill you because there's
no medicine, no doctor.
Injuries that meant certain
death or a lifetime of agony and
helplessness.
Our ancestors lived, generally
speaking, short, incredibly hard
lives just filled with constant
fear and physical pain.
Survival wasn't optional, it was
a full time job against these
raw forces.
There was no headspace for
existential angst when you were
literally fighting to see the
next sunrise.
Right.
The anxiety was about the lion
outside The Cave, not the e-mail
in your inbox.
And that.
Historical context isn't just
like background color.
It's crucial because it throws
our current reality into such
sharp relief, a reality we
almost completely take for
granted.
Those harsh conditions shaped
everything for millennia.
Human, psychology, society,
everything revolved around basic
survival.
Decision making was immediate
physical life or death.
So remembering that grim
backdrop helps you appreciate
how unbelievably unique and
frankly, privileged your
situation likely is right now,
even on a bad day.
It's a perspective check for
sure.
A massive 1.
It highlights the almost
miraculous progress we've made.
Progress.
We just swim in like water,
barely noticing we've largely
transcended that basic survival
fight in ways our ancestors
couldn't even dream of.
Which?
Makes our modern suffering kind
of a paradox.
Exactly.
A paradox built on forgetting
just how good we actually have
it, physically speaking.
OK, so now we get to the guru's
big observation, the real pivot
point, he writes.
But my guru wrote, in the modern
world, at least for most people
in developed countries, these
things don't have to control you
anymore.
Wow.
Just let that sink in, those
ancient struggles, the eschit
that dominated human life
forever.
They don't have to control you
now, he's saying.
Their power, their
inevitability, has been broken
for many of us.
And he lists the solutions, and
they sound almost insultingly
simple because they're so normal
for us now.
Clean water is everywhere.
Food is cheap and available.
You have a roof over your head.
Medicine exists.
Roads are safe.
Hospitals exist.
Mundane miracles.
Exactly.
Things we barely register, but
they represent a total
revolution in human experience.
It's genuinely hard to overstate
how monumental that shift is.
This is an unprecedented
liberation from that primal
physical suffering.
We turn on a tap.
Boom, clean water.
Feeling hungry, supermarkets
full, too hot, too cold.
We adjust the thermostat.
Sick.
We see a doctor get medicine
that actually works.
These aren't just minor
conveniences, they are the
result of centuries of effort
that have, for many people,
effectively eliminated the
constant grinding fight for
basic survival it.
Frees up so much energy
bandwidth.
Exactly, mental and physical
energy.
It allows for a whole different
level of living where survival
isn't the main focus and
connecting us to the bigger
picture.
Like you said, it explains why
our anxieties are so different
now.
Our ancestors worried about
starving, we worry about gluten.
They worry about dying from
infection.
We worry about optimizing our
sleep schedule.
Yeah, it sounds absurd when you
put it like that.
It kind of is.
The very nature of common
suffering has fundamentally
changed for a huge portion of
humanity.
That physical shit is largely
optional now.
It's a profound transformation
we overlook, which leads us to
magnify problems that,
historically speaking, are
luxuries.
And the guru doesn't just state
the general principle, he then
goes through the 1st 7 items on
the shit list, 1 by 1 and offers
the modern solution with like
almost comical simplicity.
OK.
Let's hear them right.
He's not denying these states
exist.
You still get thirsty,
obviously, but he's hitting home
how avoidable the prolonged
suffering from them is.
Got it.
So thirst.
His answer?
Drink water.
Simple enough.
Hunger.
Eat something?
Check.
Exposure to the elements?
Go indoors.
Obvious.
Yeah.
Sickness, take care of your body
and, crucially, see a doctor.
Right, use the resources.
Horniness.
OK, this ones interesting, he
says.
Take care of yourself or let it
pass.
Pragmatic.
No judgment, just manage it.
Exactly, injury, avoid
carelessness and again, medical
care exists.
Be mindful, use the safety net.
Tiredness.
Yeah.
Go to sleep, OK?
Seems straightforward he's.
Not being dismissive, right?
He's hammering home the sheer
accessibility of these fixes for
so many of us.
These aren't epic quests
anymore, no.
Exactly.
The core theme running through
all of that is these are
choices.
These are actions readily
available to most people in
developed countries.
They're not insurmountable
barriers like they used to be,
right?
And his take on horniness is
great I think.
Super pragmatic, totally non
judgmental, Acknowledges it's a
natural urge, offers 2 practical
options.
Deal with it directly or let the
impulse subside.
No drama, no shame, just mindful
management so it doesn't hijack
your peace.
Yeah.
It doesn't let it become this
huge consuming thing.
Exactly, And with sickness and
injury.
Sure, severe cases are still
awful, and he's not denying that
pain.
But his point is that so many
instances of suffering from
everyday sickness or minor
injuries can be massively
reduced or avoided altogether
through preventative care, basic
hygiene, vaccinations, healthy
habits, by taking personal
responsibility, and critically,
by having access to medical help
that our ancestors could only
dream of.
A toothache could kill you back
then.
A cut could lead to amputation
now usually it's an
inconvenience.
Treatable.
Massive perspective shift.
He keeps reinforcing the
accessibility for most people
hearing this.
These aren't heroic feats, they
are simple everyday decisions.
Be proactive, don't just
passively accept prolonged
discomfort from these basic
physical things.
That's the modern advantage, OK.
So if that's true, if water,
food, shelter, medicine, safety,
if they're all relatively easy
to access for many of us, then
we hit the big question.
The paradox.
All this primal eschit is
largely solvable if you choose
to solve it.
Yet people still suffer a lot
constantly.
Why the?
Physical stuff is mostly handed.
Why is misery so, so widespread?
And the guru delivers the
answer, the pivot we talked
about.
The reason, he says, is because
of the last one.
Your.
Brain the internal culprit.
And this really is the absolute
crux of it all, isn't it?
The whole deep dive hinges on
this shift.
We move from looking at external
circumstances, which OK, largely
manageable for many, to looking
inward at the internal
landscape, our thoughts,
emotions, perceptions.
And it's this realm that for
most people, just runs wild,
unchecked, unmanaged,
unquestioned.
Like a toddler with a megaphone.
Yeah, something like that.
And it forces you to ask, if my
physical suffering is largely
optional now, what does that
imply about the nature of most
of my current suffering?
Is it really caused by external
events or is the root cause much
closer right between my ears it?
Demands some real honesty.
Looking inward like that it.
Really does identifying the true
source.
So let's talk about this brain.
Our brain.
The guru calls it tricky, which
I think we can agree is a
massive understatement.
World class understatement.
Yeah, he explains.
Its original job, its
evolutionary purpose.
It evolved to keep you alive
thousands of years ago when the
world was dangerous.
Makes sense.
Survival.
Machine, right?
But here's the kicker, it still
acts like you're in that world.
Oof, yeah, that hits.
Think about it.
This incredibly sophisticated
survival mechanism honed over
countless generations to be
hyper alert to threats,
brilliant at spotting predators,
sensing danger from rival
tribes.
Essential skills back then is.
Now operating an OverDrive in a
world where those immediate
physical life and death threats
are mostly gone.
For many of us, it's like
having, I don't know, a
state-of-the-art smoke detector
that goes off every time you
make toast.
Perfect analogy.
Overly sensitive for the current
environment.
It's this powerful engine, but
it's running on outdated maps,
constantly flagging things as
danger, danger, danger when
they're really just inconvenient
or annoying or uncertain.
It's that classic evolutionary
mismatch we hear about.
Yeah, our biology hasn't caught
up with our environment.
Exactly.
That primal brain, amazing for
dodging lions, is now freaking
out over work emails for
someone, cutting you off in
traffic, or seeing someone
else's perfect life on
Instagram.
Or just vague worries about the
future.
Right.
Abstract threats, Yeah.
Job security, climate change,
What people think of you.
That ancient wiring so
beneficial then becomes this
huge source of unnecessary
stress now in our relatively
safe world.
It triggers the same fight or
flight response for an angry
comment online as it might have
for a charging bore.
Pretty much, which is why your
internal stress can feel so
disproportionate, so
overwhelming, even when
objectively you're perfectly
safe.
Powerful engine, outdated
instructions, constantly
sounding alarms for ghosts.
So how exactly does this tricky,
outdated brain torment us?
The guru lists the ways, and
man, they are relatable.
It tells you to worry, to fear,
to stay alert even when you're
safe.
Check, check and check.
It invents threats and repeats
old pain.
Oh.
Yeah, the classic.
It creates suffering out of
nothing.
It's like this non-stop internal
commentary of doom and gloom,
isn't it?
Or just dissatisfaction it.
Really is.
Let's break those down a bit
because they capture so much of
the modern human condition.
First, worry and fear.
That's the brain constantly
jumping into the future, playing
out worst case scenarios.
The endless what if loop.
Usually about stuff that never
actually happens.
Exactly how often do you catch
your mind spinning these
elaborate horror stories about,
I don't know, a presentation
next week or a doctor's
appointment or what someone
might think?
It steals your present moment,
worrying about a future that
isn't real?
Totally.
Drains your battery second.
Staying alert when safe.
That feeling of never quite
being able to switch off.
That low level hum of anxiety,
even when you're just sitting on
the couch.
Yeah, like you're waiting for
the other shoe to drop.
Precisely.
It makes it hard to truly relax,
truly rest.
It can lead to that generalized
anxiety or insomnia, even when
you're physically comfortable
and secure.
Your body might be safe, but
your mind's still on patrol
duty.
Scanning the horizon for
imaginary threats. 3rd, it
invents threats.
This is where the brain gets
creative.
It imagines slights where the
nun were intended, anticipates
criticism, builds these complex
dramas about social rejection or
professional failure.
Based on zero evidence.
Sometimes.
Often.
You replay conversation and
twist someone's words into an
insult.
You walk into a room and assume
everyone's judging you.
It's a master fiction writer
creating stress out of thin air,
mountains out of molehills, or
maybe just out of nothing.
The internal narrator is often
unreliable.
Very unreliable. 4th It repeats
old pain.
This one's cruel.
The brain's tendency to just
loop past mistakes, embarrassing
moments old hurts, grudges like.
Watching reruns of your worst
moments.
Exactly, you effectively re
experience the suffering
sometimes years or decades
later.
Event is long gone but the mind
keeps digging it up,
reactivating those pain
pathways.
It stops you from healing by
constantly picking the scab.
And finally it creates suffering
out of nothing.
This is maybe the most
insidious.
It's the existential stuff, that
constant craving for more.
More money, more status, more
stuff, more like.
Not enough feeling.
Yes, the feeling of inadequacy.
The endless comparison game,
especially fueled by social
media, the longing for external
validation, or things you think
will make you happy but never
quite do.
The if only I had X then I'd be
happy trap that's.
The one.
These are purely mental
constructs, desires the brain
just generates, and when they
aren't met instantly, which they
really are, boom, suffering,
lack, emptiness.
The grass is always greener,
keeping you perpetually
dissatisfied.
Wow, laid out like that, it's
quite an indictment of the
default human mind.
Well, as.
The guru puts it simply and
directly.
Most people let their brain run
wild and it ruins their peace.
And it's not meant as a harsh
judgment, I don't think.
It's just an observation of this
incredibly common tendency.
We lack conscious management of
our inner world.
We let this ancient
overprotective guard run the
show even when the war is long
over.
Like having a Ferrari with no
steering wheel, all power, no
direction, constantly crashing.
That's a good way to put it.
It crashes into self-made walls
of suffering.
OK, but here's the hope.
Here's the antidote the guru
offers, and it's not what you
might expect.
He doesn't say fight your brain
or force it to be quiet.
That usually backfires anyway.
Trying to suppress thoughts
makes them louder.
Exactly.
Instead, he offers something
more subtle, more powerful, he
says.
But as my guru said, you don't
have to listen to it.
You can notice the lies it
tells.
Notice the lies.
That's the key phrase.
It's not about stopping the
thoughts, it's about changing
your relationship to them,
gaining perspective, disengaging
from the drama.
Yes.
That's where the real
transformation happens.
Noticing the lies is the
practice.
It's not suppression, it's
observation stepping back,
creating a little space between
you, the observer, and the
thought stream your brain
produces.
Like watching traffic go by
instead of jumping into every
car.
Perfect.
You recognize these thoughts,
the worries, the fears, the
desires, as just mental events,
transient phenomena, not
absolute truths, not commands.
You have to obey.
This is core mindfulness,
really.
You might try this when a worry
pops up, instead of getting
sucked into the story, just
label it silently Say to
yourself, ah worry.
Or there's that, not good enough
thought again.
Or planning mind is active.
Just acknowledging it neutrally.
Exactly.
That simple act of noticing and
naming creates distance.
You're not fighting it, you're
just not buying into it
wholesale.
You let it float by like a
cloud.
You can use your breath as an
anchor.
When the thought arises,
acknowledge it.
Then gently return your focus to
your breath.
The.
Thought loses its grip then
often.
Often, yeah, because you see it
as separate from your core self,
just a product of the brains
programming, not necessarily
reality.
And the cool thing is, with
practice, this noticing actually
starts to rewire the brain.
Neuroplasticity.
You build new calmer pathways.
So.
It's a skill you develop.
Absolutely.
It's training the mind.
And then the guru offers this
huge reframe, this perspective
shift designed to dissolve a lot
of that manufactured suffering.
Instantly, he says.
You can see that you are alive
right now in a time and place
where you are safer and more
comfortable than almost any
human who has ever lived.
And then you already live in
conditions would have seemed
like paradise to your ancestors.
Paradise again, with that word,
it feels almost jarring compared
to how we usually feel
day-to-day.
It is jarring because it's true
for so many of us, but we're
completely blind to it most of
the time.
It's not hyperbole, it's a
factual statement about our
baseline conditions.
The.
Implications of really taking
that on board, they're huge.
Immense.
How often do you, listening,
actually pause and feel the
sheer, almost unbelievable
luxury of your existence?
Compared to 99.9% of human
history?
Probably.
Never or very rarely.
Right.
Think about it.
Indoor plumbing, instant global
communication, climate control,
food from all over the world
available 24/7.
Electricity, The Internet,
Nearly all human knowledge in
your pocket.
Comfortable beds, clean water on
demand.
Things we just expect.
We expect them, but even kings
and Queens centuries ago didn't
have most of this stuff.
Your ancestors, struggling
against the raw elements, would
view your average modern
apartment with reliable heating
and Wi-Fi as literal paradise
and unimaginable utopia.
So truly realizing that
cultivating that perspective,
that gratitude, it can dismantle
so much of the brains invented
suffering when you genuinely
feel, wow, I'm living in
conditions my ancestors would
have called paradise.
Suddenly, that worry about a
minor work deadline or a social
media comment, it shrinks.
It loses its power, its urgency,
it.
Puts things in perspective.
A very large perspective.
Exactly.
It grounds you in the incredible
reality of your present
privilege.
Which brings us to how the guru
redefines Nirvana.
And it's really different from
how most people probably think
about it.
He challenges those, you know,
mystical, far off ideas.
Makes it accessible he.
Says this, he said, is what
Buddhism has been pointing to
all along.
Nirvana is not a faraway place.
It's not only for monks.
It's not locked in a temple.
Takes you right off the
pedestal.
Completely demolishes that image
of Nirvana.
Nirvana as some impossible state
only reachable by spiritual
superheroes after decades of
effort or some reward you get
after you die.
He brings it right down to earth
right here and.
That's revolutionary because it
deconstructs those common, often
intimidating misconceptions.
It pulls Nirvana out of the
realm of the mystical and makes
it tangible for you.
Now.
It's not this abstract reward
for extreme effort, not just for
the spiritual lead not found in
some specific building.
It makes Nirvana Democratic
accessible.
So if it's not out there, where
is it?
Well, connecting the dots, it
reframes the whole spiritual
path, doesn't it?
It's not an external quest to
find something, It's an internal
shift, a change in your
awareness right where you are.
It suggests peace isn't
something you add, it's what's
left when you remove the layers
of unnecessary suffering and
misunderstanding.
OK, so how does he define it
then?
Concretely, he.
Makes it beautifully simple,
beautifully immediate.
Nirvana is here now when
suffering ends.
Full stop.
That's it.
That's the core definition he
offers.
No complex theology needed, just
the end of suffering.
And then he explains how that
happens, keeping it super
practical.
It's what happens when you take
care of your basic needs and
stop letting your brain torture
you with fear and longing.
The two-part formula again,
handle the physical shit, then
handle the mental brain shit.
And that really is the essence
of it, isn't it?
Elegantly put, Nirvana isn't
some prize you chase, it's the
natural state that just emerges
when two things happen. 1 You
consciously manage the physical
stuff.
Food, water, shelter, rest,
health which for many now is
doable.
You take care of the body's
basic requirements too.
And this is the big one for
modern life.
You consciously address the
mental brain shit, the
self-inflicted suffering from
that runaway mind.
You recognize it, you challenge
it, you disarm it by not
believing it's lies.
And he specifically calls out
fear and longing.
Let's focus on those for a
second because they really are
the twin engines driving so much
of the brains self generated
suffering today.
Fear is usually about the
future, right?
Fear of what might happen, fear
of losing what you have, fear of
failure, of judgement, of not
being enough.
It manifests as anxiety about
work, money, health,
relationships, the world.
Constant projection into
potential negative outcomes.
Exactly.
And longing.
That's about perceive lack,
about what's absent, craving
what you don't have but think
you need for happiness, more
money, a better job, a different
partner, a perfect body, some
future state of bliss.
It's the if only syndrome
comparison, dissatisfaction with
the present.
Never content, right?
So the guru implies that when
these dominant mental patterns,
projecting fear into the future
and projecting desire or lack
onto the present, when they stop
running the show, when you stop
feeding them energy by believing
them, peace just naturally
arises.
It's what's underneath which.
Really makes you wonder what
would life feel like if your
mind wasn't constantly hijacked
by fear and longing?
What clarity, what contentment
might just be there.
It's a.
Profound question to sit with,
isn't it?
What becomes possible when those
filters are removed?
OK, but now we get to maybe the
most challenging part of the
e-mail.
The guru shares what he calls
the sad truth, and it's
uncomfortable but also deeply
insightful.
It really makes you look hard at
yourself and maybe people you
know.
Uh oh.
What's the sad truth?
He writes.
Most people don't really want
Nirvana.
Whoa, OK, didn't expect that,
right?
He continues.
They say they do, but they cling
to their suffering because it
feels familiar.
Cling.
A suffering because it's
familiar?
That sounds messed up.
Why would anyone do that?
It's a tough pill to swallow,
isn't it?
To think we might actually hold
on to our own misery.
It really is.
That's probably the most
provocative statement so far.
Why on earth would we cling to
pain?
It seems totally
counterintuitive.
Yeah.
But psychologically, Yeah, Maybe
there's something there.
Yeah.
What do you think?
Well, first, there's definitely
the power of familiarity and
identity.
Suffering, or the story you tell
about your suffering, can become
central to who you think you
are.
I'm the anxious one.
I'm the one who always
struggles.
Life's always been hard for me
it.
Becomes your brand.
Almost.
Kind of.
It's the known territory.
Even if it's unpleasant, letting
go of that familiar pain can
feel like letting go of your
identity.
Who are you?
Without the struggle?
It can be genuinely
disorienting.
The unknown of peace might feel
scarier than the known pain.
That's a sobering thought.
Second, the viewer mentions they
hold on to their pain because it
gives them something to talk
about, something to blame.
This points to attention,
validation, maybe what
psychologists call secondary
gains, meaning meaning suffering
can get you things, sympathy,
attention, connection.
Even if it's through shared
complaining, it could be an
excuse for not trying or for
perceived failures.
Well, I couldn't do X because I
was feeling so why?
A built in justification
sometimes, yeah.
It can even create a weird sense
of specialness.
My problems are unique, My pain
is deep.
If you let go of the suffering
narrative, what do you talk
about?
How do you get that attention or
validation?
Wow.
That's all uncomfortably
perceptive. 3rd Just the raw
fear of the unknown.
Living without that familiar
internal battle sounds good, but
it can also be terrifying.
What would you do with all that
mental space and energy if it
wasn't consumed by worry or
resentment?
What new challenges or
responsibilities might surface?
Change is scary, even change for
the better.
Our brains crave predictability,
even painful predictability.
Yeah, better the devil you know.
And fourth, maybe the biggest
one, avoidance of
responsibility.
If suffering is, as the guru
suggests, largely optional and
driven by your brain, well, that
puts the onus on you to change
it, right?
No more blaming the world, or
your boss or your past.
Exactly.
It means taking ownership of
your internal state, and that
requires courage, self honesty,
effort.
It's often easier, frankly, to
feel like a victim of
circumstances than to accept
that the power and the
responsibility lies within your
own mind.
It's daunting it.
Is so when the guru says they'd
rather keep their misery than
let it go, it's less a judgement
and more of really challenging
observation.
It invites you to look honestly.
Are you holding on to any
suffering because it's familiar?
Because it serves some hidden
purpose?
Because taking responsibility
feels too hard?
A.
Call for radical self honesty.
Totally a moment to really
question your own relationship
with your own mind.
But he doesn't just leave us
there.
In that uncomfortable
realization, he immediately
offers the empowering way out,
the reminder of our choice, our
agency.
Good.
Because that was getting a bit
heavy.
Ha ha, yeah, he says simply.
But you don't have to.
You can choose differently.
That's the core, the power to
choose your response, to choose
a different path.
Agency returns.
And then he neatly wraps up the
practical approach again.
The two steps to freedom.
You can handle the shit.
Thirst, hunger, exposure,
sickness, horniness, injury,
tiredness.
Because our world makes that
easy.
Step one, manage the physical.
Right.
Be proactive with the basics.
Then you can learn to quiet the
brain, the last and biggest
cause of suffering.
Step 2.
Manage the mental.
Master the internal world.
It really boils down to that
twofold path, and the emphasis
on learn to quiet the brain is
key.
Why?
Because it signals that this is
a process, a skill, not magic.
The guru's message is ultimately
about personal agency, yes, but
it's grounded in conscious
choice and consistent effort.
It's not wishful thinking it.
Takes practice exactly.
Learning to quiet the brain
implies practice, developing
awareness, perseverance.
It's a journey built on those
small repeated moments of
noticing the lies, choosing not
to engage, returning to the
present, maybe using the breath
as an anchor.
Micro moments adding up.
Precisely taking one conscious
breath when you feel anxiety
rising.
Labeling a worry is just a
thought.
Gently redirecting your
attention away from the
catastrophic story your brain is
spinning, setting boundaries
with things that trigger
comparison or longing.
Actively engaging with your
inner world?
Yes.
To cultivate peace.
Recognizing your mind is
powerful, but it's an instrument
you can learn to play.
Rather than letting it play, you
puts the control firmly back in
your hands.
The freedom of conscious choice.
That's incredibly empowering.
So wrapping this all up, what
does it really mean for you
listening right now, living your
life?
This whole deep dive into just
one e-mail?
It's given us this radical but
also really practical idea that
so much of our suffering,
especially in this modern age of
relative comfort and safety,
isn't some unavoidable fate.
It's not written in the stars.
It's a choice largely driven by
this unmanaged mind, this brain
running ancient software in a
modern world, and.
The guru's final piece of wisdom
just nails it.
I think it sums everything up.
Nirvana is right in front of you
right here.
You don't have to earn it.
You don't have to chase it.
Not.
A reward, not a destination.
You.
Only have to stop believing the
suffering your brain gives you.
Wow, stop believing it.
That's the core action.
Peace isn't somewhere else.
It's not something to achieve.
It's potentially the default
state accessible right now just
by disengaging, by withdrawing
belief from the fear, the worry,
the longing that your brain
churns out constantly.
It's already here underneath the
noise if you choose to tune into
it and stop buying the brains BS
basically.
Peace is already here, if you're
willing to take it.
Yeah, that's a powerful final
thought from the guru.
So as you reflect on all this,
what really stands out for you?
What old physical, or maybe more
likely mental, might you be
clinging on to that's actually
optional?
What old stories?
What familiar miseries or you
may be holding on to?
And maybe the biggest question,
what could your life actually
feel like?
What might transform for you if
you really dare to stop
believing the suffering your own
brain is feeding you?
This e-mail isn't just
information.
It's an invitation.
An invitation to actively choose
your state of being, to claim
the paradise that maybe, just
maybe, is already here.